welcome back okay in the last lecture we derived
the wave equation for a vibrating guitar string uh
from scratch from f equals ma physics um literally
just you know conservation of momentum of a little
infinitesimal section of guitar string vibrating
up and down you know being forced by its own
tension essentially the tension in the string
so we derived this equation from scratch
where the wave speed c is related to the
material properties of the guitar string
c is literally the square root of the
tension divided by the linear density
so increasing the tension increases the wave speed
which makes higher pitched sounds decreasing the
tension makes it lower pitched i massively
detuned my guitar last time but it's back
to in tune and the linear density a thicker
string a thicker heavier string like the low e
will have a lower wave speed because it has a
higher row than a thinner lighter high e string
right so this one the low one has a
bigger row smaller c the lighter one
has a smaller row higher c and that
translates to either a lower pitch sound
or a higher pitched sound so what we're going
to do today is from this uh wave equation
we're now going to solve this for some specific
boundary conditions literally for this guitar
boundary condition where it's pinned uh kind of
here and here at the at the bridge and at the neck
and then we're going to analyze what happens you
know to this wave equation what happens what are
the solutions of this wave equation and how does
that translate into intuitive things we know you
know from from music from sound from things like
that okay uh so that's all coming up but we're
going to solve this using separation of variables
one of the most important solution techniques for
partial differential equations um i want to
point out just uh i hope you appreciate i
hike i hiked my guitar up three miles from
home to to film today so i hope you appreciate
uh the dedication i thought about just playing
air guitar but i figured this would be a lot
more interesting just uh preface at the very
beginning you know i am a complete amateur
novice i know zero music theory my wife
likes to joke that you know all i know is
string theory for the wave equation and the
string i don't really know any music theory
but i do think uh that this is a
really intuitive kind of example
because music much like mathematics i think
resonates very much with the kind of logical
part of our brain but we also know when it
feels right and so that meeting place of kind of
thought and feeling i think is very much shared
between mathematics and music and in fact there
are deep deep connections between music and
mathematics that people have been exploring
and uncovering for hundreds of years for centuries
if not millennia so even if you go back this is a
little bit of a just a history digression but
i think it's interesting if you go back uh to
you know tico bray and kepler before um galileo
before newton before we knew about f equals ma and
before we had you know proven that the the sun was
the center of the solar system when things were
still speculative and people didn't understand
why the planets behave the way that they did
there was a theory and kepler held on very
strongly to this theory that there were harmonic
patterns in the motion of the planets and the
motion of the stars just like musical patterns and
layers uh you know the defined musical composition
they believed that there were these patterns
in the stars and the heavens and the planets
and that that musical composition was perhaps
divine and definitely had an impact in our daily
lives right this is astrology um you know from
the olden days it always had this flavor of you
know one part mathematics and one part music just
fascinating i think oh and uh yeah in in lugging
uh my guitar to work today i was thinking back a
friend of mine taught me a new word called
busking so busking is when you bring your
your guitar or musical instrument and you play in
public in a public space and i think it's a super
fun busking uh comes from the spanish word uh
buskar which means to seek you know to seek out or
something and so we are all you know in some sense
busking and buskers because we're all seeking
uh seeking knowledge this is a very very meta you
know two steps removed online youtube version of
busking i suppose okay good so i'm going to jump
right into this um we're going to solve this
equation using separation of variables uh maybe
i'll just write it here separation of variables
which we've already seen before when we solve
laplace's equation for the heat distribution
in a rectangular metal plate here we're going to
solve for uh kind of you know the the vibration
the motion of the string where it's pinned in two
locations at x equals zero and x equals l l is the
length of my string and so again for a partial
differential equation to be well defined we need
to define its boundary conditions and its initial
condition so i'm going to do that here i'm going
to say just to be very very clear u of x and t is
the height of the spur of the string the height
or kind of the height or the displacement of
that string the displacement of the string
and it's going to be a function
of x the position along the string
and in time it's going to be
oscillating in space and in time
and our boundary conditions our boundary
conditions are essentially u at x equals zero
for all of time is going to equal zero so we've
essentially pinned the string in one position up
at the up at the neck and that is going to be a
zero displacement for all time this is at the at
the neck and similarly at the bridge at the at the
other end of the string u of sorry it's so squeaky
um is also equal to zero so at length l for
all time it's also pinned in that location
but it can kind of do whatever it wants
in the middle okay so i can i can you know
deflect the string you know i can pull the
string with my finger and make it a little
shallow triangle uh that's totally fine as long
as it stays pinned at both of the boundaries
and then the last thing i need is my initial
condition maybe i'll switch colors so it's not so
squeaky oh still squeaky my initial condition is
going to be u at x at time zero so now my remember
my boundary conditions are for all time at spatial
boundaries my initial condition is at a given time
at my initial time t 0 at all of the positions x
i'm just going to define the displacement at time
0 to be some function of x and this function of
x could be you know that i take my guitar string
and i you know essentially pull up on the
guitar string in one place and then i let it go
that could be my f of x is that it's this little
triangle from me pulling up you know and about to
with my pick or with my finger so i have boundary
conditions and initial conditions which make this
a well-posed partial differential equation
it's a linear partial differential equation
which means that superposition holds it means that
if i have you know multiple solutions and i add
them up if i have multiple solutions that satisfy
my boundary conditions and i add them up then
they're still going to be a solution of my partial
differential equation that's nice and we're going
to solve this using separation of variables just
like we did before so i'm gonna i'm gonna jump in
so our separation of variables assumption
the basic basic assumption here is that um u
of x and t my function of space and time is
separate is separable which means that i can write
this as a product of a function just of x f of x
times a function g that's just a function of time
so this is the basic basic assumption of
separation of variables is that i can say that my
solution which varies in space and time remember
that that guitar string is vibrating in space
and in time but i'm going to assume this is an
assumption that it can be written as a product
of a function just of space times a function just
of time and when we plug this into our pde and
go through all of the steps we're going to see if
that assumption holds and if we can get a solution
that satisfies these boundary
conditions and initial conditions
good uh so so that's what we're gonna do and
maybe i will just start writing out what the
derivatives are i think that's a good place
to start we're going to plug it into this pde
so we need to be able to compute u
t t and u x x pretty simple so uh u
t t is just the second partial derivative of this
with respect to time so that's you know f of x
times g double prime t good and similarly u x x is
f double prime x times g of t pretty pretty simple
stuff here okay and because we know that um u t
equals c squared u x x i can use these expressions
to essentially say that f x g double prime
t equals c squared f double prime x g of t
okay uh good and so now just like uh we've
done in the past what we're going to do
is we're going to collect all of the functions of
x on one side and all the functions of g on the
other side and we're going to try to turn those
into ordinary differential equations just of x
and just of t okay so we're going to try to take
this spatial temporal problem this this function
of two variables x and t and break it down into
you know just a problem in x and just a problem
in t that we can solve using our kind of basic ode
uh technology that we are very comfortable with
okay and i always forget you know where i
should keep my c should i keep my constant
on the x terms or on the um on the time terms
i think i'm going to keep the i think i'm going
to move my c's over so i think what i'm going to
do is i'm going to say i have f double prime of x
over f of x i'm going to divide both sides by f
i'm going to divide both sides by g and i'm going
to divide both sides by c squared so this equals
one over c squared g double prime t over g of t
you can you know pause the video slow it down
whatever but all i've done is i've divided both
sides by f double prime by g double prime and
divided by c squared so that the c squared is now
with my functions of time and this is where um in
the last you know video where i did separation of
variables for laplace's equation i made a
really big point of emphasizing that if i
have a function that's just a function of x and
i have a function that's just a function of time
and they equal each other then they both have to
be equal to a constant this has to equal some some
k some you know i should not spell constant with a
k but this is a constant okay this is a constant k
okay so and that's again because this is
just a function of x and this is just a
function of t and for those to be equal to
each other it has to equal some constant k
and you know maybe what i'll do because i you know
that these are going to be eigenvalues i'm just
going to call that constant k some constant lambda
okay uh some some constant lambda and in fact
i'm going to make it lambda squared because
i know it's going to be a positive constant
we'll we'll get there maybe
maybe i'll just call it lambda
good
so i should point out okay i'll i'll do you know
the next step is going to be solving you know
just taking f double prime x over f equals lambda
and solving that ordinary differential equation in
x uh you know presumably with these boundary
conditions and then doing the same thing for
the time ordinary differential equation and then
combining those that's what we do in separation of
variables i'll point out um you know i i mentioned
in the last video that the wave equation is
something i actually don't usually dive too much
into depth uh in my class um it's something you
know i've spent a lot of time uh over the years
contemplating the wave equation it's never been my
favorite pde that i felt really really comfortable
with it's super important it's everywhere and over
the last few days i have just been you know
wandering around uh like a planet planet means
wanderer so i've just been wandering around um you
know listening to guitar music and thinking about
the wave equation and its solution and when i
derived this out as kind of a test run of this
video i got all the signs wrong my c's were all in
the wrong place so i just want you to know that if
it looks like uh well if it goes really smoothly
it didn't the first time and if it doesn't go very
smoothly uh you are forewarned okay this is the
kind of thing you've got to be really careful
uh to keep track of the signs and where the seas
are and all of that stuff and for me personally
the only way i can keep track of it is to have
some idea of the physical intuition of what i want
my solution to look like so maybe before i solve
this i'm going to just go back to the physics here
we have a guitar string that's pinned in two
places at the you know one condition x equals zero
and another x equals l l the length of the string
the only solutions that can satisfy those two
boundary conditions essentially have to be sine
waves that have you know a period of l something
like sine of you know uh x pi over l or sine of
2 pi x over l or 3 pi x over l or 4 pi x over l
those are the only you know basic solutions
that can satisfy these two boundary conditions
um and so i kind of already know that my functions
of x my f of x are going to be signs with that
period and so that's going to help me figure out
should my lambda be positive or negative you know
things like that so um let's hope i get it right
if i don't we'll fix it good so now what we're
going to do so step zero essentially was you know
the basic assumption of separation of variables
uh step one is you know computing all
of the derivatives and getting to this
point here so step one is computing all these
derivatives and kind of arriving at this basic
um expression here and now step two
i'm gonna break it up into two parts
i'm gonna solve the ode for the functions of x and
i'm gonna solve the ode for the functions of time
so uh and let's call this 2a because there's
two parts to this what i want to point out
is i always want to pick the one that's easiest
to solve first where i have more information
and if you notice here it looks like my boundary
conditions are pretty simple i have you know fixed
pinned boundary conditions at x equals zero and
x equals l and so i'm pretty sure my functions of
space are going to be sine waves with that length
l period so i think that it's going to be easier
to solve these f equations first and then once
that determines uniquely what this constant is
again this constant is going to determine
be determined somehow by this length l
once i determine what that constant
is and what these solutions are
then i can solve for how those vary in time
so i'm going to start with my functions f
that's just generally speaking a good
idea to start with the easy stuff first
and so here we have an equation that's
something like um you know f double prime x
over f of x equals uh maybe i will call this uh
lambda squared but i think i think i remember what
issue i had when i was deriving this a couple of
days ago is that i am used to this constant being
positive this lambda squared and when i used a
positive constant here let's let's say this is
lambda squared when i used a positive constant
i got the wrong solutions to this ordinary
differential equation i'm looking for sines and
cosines in x and i think i got like exponential
functions uh in x which is not right and so i i
had to remind myself that this could be a negative
constant this this constant that both of these
equal this can totally be a negative constant
so this is going to make my life a lot easier and
i think what you what you should do for those of
you at home is you should try this for a positive
constant and work out what those solutions f of
x are and convince yourself that you can't
possibly satisfy these boundary conditions
with the exponential functions you
get with a positive lambda squared
but when you use negative lambda squared we're
going to get sines and cosines out which make it
so we can satisfy these boundary conditions so
i'm kind of skipping a couple of minutes of uh
you know existential crisis for you and we're
just going to you know use the prior knowledge
i had that this should probably be a negative
constant but you could figure this out yourself
this this constant at this point is completely
undetermined it can be anything you like
and i'm using lambda squared because this is
a second order equation and it's just going to
be easier to to have it be lambda squared
you could just call this some constant k
and work it all out yourself okay so what we have
here and we're just going to switch back to yellow
is that we have f double prime plus lambda
squared f equals 0. and since this is this
is not a partial differential equation this is
an ordinary differential equation it has one
independent variable x and so this this ordinary
differential equation is easy to solve we know
how to solve second order linear differential
equations this is essentially the equation for a
mass on a spring and this lambda squared
is the square of that spring frequency
the frequency of oscillation so that's again
why i needed this to be negative so that when i
multiplied f and added it i got a spring equation
that has a plus and minus i omega eigenvalue
okay and so essentially we know that this
is going to have solutions f of x equals
and how do i want to write this
this is going to have f of x
equals some constant i'll
call it you know alpha cosine
of lambda x plus some other constant beta
sine lambda x okay good so this is just
what happens when you solve this differential
equation you get a cosine and a sine component
again you can go back to your kind of basic
linear ordinary differential equations to
solve this this is the solution and what we know
is that the only way that this this function f
can satisfy both boundary conditions being zero
at x equals zero and x equals l is essentially
you know cosine is not going to be ever zero at
x equals zero so the only way we can solve this
is to have the alpha all of these terms equal
to zero no cosine part because cosine of zero
is always equal to one okay so it can't satisfy
this left boundary condition unless alpha is zero
and the only way that sine of lambda x can satisfy
this boundary condition is if lambda equals
pi over l times some integer
n where n you know equals one
two three dot dot dot it could also equal zero
um let's put zero in there it could be zero one
two three dot dot dot it could also be negative
one negative two negative three that's all fine
but the only way that this can satisfy the
zero boundary conditions that x equals zero
and x equals l is if lambda equals pi over l times
some integer okay and so essentially what we get
is that f of x f of x equals
uh let's just call this um
beta n because there's going to be a constant
for every integer n beta n sine of n pi over l
times x uh where you know lambda equals pi over
l pi over l times times n okay good so we have
solved kind of half of our ordinary differential
equation so we've solved the functions of
x the only way they can satisfy these boundary
conditions is for very particular lambda remember
special values are eigenvalues
so these lambda are eigenvalues
of this ordinary differential equation f
double prime x plus lambda squared f of x
equals zero this ordinary differential equation
has eigenvalues plus and minus i lambda
and that gives cosine of lambda x plus sine
of lambda x type solutions the signs are the
only ones that can satisfy the pinned boundary
conditions here and they can only satisfy it for
very special lambda for very special values so
that that sign is equal to zero at x equals zero
that that's true for any lambda but for it to be
equal to zero at x equals l then lambda l sine of
lambda l has to equal zero and that has to be sine
of lambda l uh you know has to be some integer
multiple of pi okay and so essentially this is
the solution for all the functions in x good and
so we've done two super important things here in
this step we have determined that the only spatial
solutions to this uh partial differential equation
can only be built out of sine functions in x
and we've also determined out of all of the
possible constants that these could equal
lambda has to be a very very special constant an
eigenvalue constant given by a pi n over l where
n is an integer and l is the length of my string
so we've determined that our eigenvalue has to be
pi n over l to satisfy these boundary conditions
and that our functions of of x are signs you know
with that frequency good so that was believe
it or not that was the easy part and now for
2b we're going to solve the same equations in
g for the temporal dynamics for these g of t
coefficients here so let's do that and i actually
this one's not going to be super hard now i just
want to make sure i give myself space to
do it so maybe i'll just do it right here
so for 2b we're going to be solving now my g
equations which are going to be something like
uh g double prime
equals minus c squared lambda squared g okay and
if i rewrite this i can say that that's g double
prime plus c squared lambda squared g pretty
simple okay and now this is kind of nice because
okay this is this equals zero
this is basically the same type of equation this
is also an ordinary differential equation that has
the same form as a mass on a spring and
now instead of the frequency being lambda
the frequency is c times lambda
here okay so similarly my g of ts
are going to be equal to some you know some
other constants i don't know what to call these
um let's call them uh i don't know k um times
cosine of c lambda t plus some other constant
c times sine of c lambda t okay good now um
we can essentially fix this lambda
we know what lambda equals it's pi
n over l so this is you know c times pi
times n over l times t that's going to be uh
like the frequency of how this string is
oscillating in time and again if i pluck a guitar
string it's generating acoustic waves based on
its oscillating frequency so this frequency here
is going to be directly tied to the frequency that
i hear when i pluck a guitar string so it's going
to depend on you know this c and on this lambda
which is a function of the length of the string
and n which are the harmonics so we'll get
to harmonics in a minute and so now how do i
figure out if this is cosine or sine or some
combination and i think what i would argue
is that because this thing starts with an initial
condition u of x comma zero at time t equals zero
i'm really only considering the cosine portion
of this because sine of c lambda t is equal to 0
at time 0. so i'm only going to use the cosine
portion of this to determine my to satisfy my
initial conditions so i'm only going to be
looking at this portion and i'm going to
explicitly plug in my lambda here and i'm going to
say this equals um you know i've got my cosine of
n of n pi c over l t and this constant k i'm
gonna say that there are n of these constants
for every integer n for each of these lambda
n uh for each of these lambda n there is a
constant outside of that that cosine good and if
you like um this this constant is basically going
to be determined by uh this fourier transform
here so i'll get back to that in a minute
okay so this actually ended up being simple now
that i had fixed this lambda from my functions
of x i use that lambda in my functions of in my
ordinary differential equation for my function
of time i solve it out i get that it also is sines
and cosines and the only way i'm going to be able
to satisfy this about this initial condition
at time 0 is through these cosine components
that i have here and so now if i combine these
two equations i essentially get my answer which is
let's see if i can not botch this it should
be pretty simple u of x and t remember it's
the product of all of these for every n for
each integer n it's the product of this sine
and this cosine and i add up all of those
solutions for all n because this is a linear
pde so all of those solutions are solutions
and when you add them up it's still a solution
so this is equal to the sum uh
let's say from n equals you know
zero to infinity of and i'm gonna just
combine these two constants my beta n
and my k n i'm gonna multiply these together
so it's just some constant n of you know sine
n pi over l x times cosine n pi c
over l t and this is the solution
of my wave equation that was the worst star
i've ever drawn so this is the solution of
my wave equation so u of x and t the the the
displacement at every point x at every point time
is given by this infinite sum of the products of
sines in x that satisfy my boundary conditions
and cosines in time and if you like what
we're gonna do the way that we determine
these coefficients is we pin we use our initial
condition we say time equals zero so all these
cosines just become one cosine of zero is one so
these go away and we basically say you know u of x
at time zero is equal to f of x is equal to
the sum of n equals zero to infinity of c n
sine n pi over l x and so that literally means
that these c n's are the fourier coefficients
if i fourier transformed my initial condition f so
these cns are literally f hat they're the fourier
transform the the discrete fourier transform
of this initial condition over that domain
zero to l okay and if if you uh if that was
a little fast for you you can go back to that
video on separation of variables for uh the
heat equation or you could go to my lecture
on the discrete fourier transform like this is
literally the definition of the fourier transform
where these guys here this is literally my f hat
fourier transform the fourier transform of f these
are my fourier coefficients of of f x that's it
that's that's the whole story that's how you solve
the wave equation using separation of variables
it's actually quite quite simple you assume
that you can split your function into a product
of a function of space and a function of time
you plug that into this partial differential
equation and take all the derivatives and get
you know a relatively simple expression and
collect all the terms and x and all the terms
in time and because those equal each other they
have to equal a constant and at this point we
don't know what this constant is it's just some
some constant k but then what you do is you try
to solve this ordinary differential equation for
just my spatial variables you know f double prime
x over f of x equals some constant and the only
way that that can satisfy my boundary conditions
is if this constant is a very very special number
pi over l times an integer the only way that we
can satisfy this boundary condition is if lambda
is pi over l times an integer so those are my
eigenvalues of this of this ordinary differential
equation or of this partial differential equation
the corresponding eigenfunctions of this are
these signs with that wavenumber with that
lambda wavenumber in x then you do the same thing
for my ordinary differential equation and time
now that i have determined what that eigenvalue
lambda has to be to satisfy my boundary conditions
i have to use that same one for my
ordinary differential equation in time
so now i get these sines and cosines in time with
a slightly different frequency and when i combine
those two solutions when i take their product
here and i add them up for all integers n i get
the solution of my partial differential
equation and what that means physically
is that the solution of this partial differential
equation i basically take my initial condition and
i you know decompose it into a bunch of signs
i take its fourier transform to find out how
i can add up infinitely many signs with you know
period l um you know all of my signs with period l
and that determines this uh this constant c for my
solution and so then each of those uh independent
kind of harmonic components each of those
independent sine waves we're literally saying
uh you know if i have some initial condition like
maybe maybe what i do is i pull up the guitar
string you know with my finger and i make this
little triangle that is equal to the sum of uh
you know this sine wave plus this sine wave plus
this sine wave and so on and so forth this is the
n equals you know one two 4 and so on and
so forth and and you know the coefficients
cn are given by the fourier transform
of my initial condition this is f x
then each of these components these wave
components of my initial condition oscillate
at a different frequency so this n equals
one component oscillates at a frequency
n pi c over l the n equals two oscillates
at twice the frequency n equals three at
three times the frequency and so on and so forth
and so essentially you know this this vibrating
guitar string is causing pressure fluctuations
in the air that it's it's sitting inside of
and that's what's creating the acoustic
waves that are radiating away from this
that you can hear when someone plays the guitar
when someone plays the piano okay it comes from
literally from this frequency here this is
going to be the frequency of sound that you hear
is is this n pi c over l and so now we actually
see very clearly and i'll pull out the guitar
again for this is we knew that the wave
speed depended on things like the tension
in the string so you know if i increase
the tension it should increase the speed
and so now we know directly that increasing
the tension will increase the frequency of
acoustic waves because this is the oscillation
in time that's creating those acoustic waves
kind of how fast this thing is flapping
in time is n pi c over l so increasing c
like increasing c by having a smaller string makes
a higher pitch sound increasing c by increasing
the tension also increases the sound but the other
thing that could you know increase the frequency
uh the pitch of the sound you hear is changing
l so if i make l smaller if i cut l in half
this frequency frequency should double so if i
take my my length and i pick the middle point of
the length i i think you can see this the middle
point here this is the 12th fret the middle point
is twice the frequency okay so changing l you know
if i if i cut l in half if i if i pin this thing
so it's half the length it's going to be twice
the frequency or i could increase the tension
by a factor of i guess in this case uh four if
i made four times the tension in the string it
would double the frequency or if i made it four
times less dense if i ever picked a material that
was four times less dense or i made it four times
smaller those would all have the same effect of
changing the frequency of the sound
Something elseI think is kind of neat, is if you picture ... I'm literally pulling this guitarstring up so it's a little very shallow triangle
when I pull it up... andthat's my initial condition...
and then I let it go
you can picture the sum of all of these waves
oscillating in time ... the amplitudes areoscillating in time to generate thatsound
and so if I just very lightly hold down the string at just a random location
you hearthat it's really damped... you don't hear anything
that sounds nice like a cord it just sounds
damped. But there are some very special locations
where some sound does come through...
here's one and... I believe this is a third harmonic, it's a third of
the length of the string. So some of these
waves have a node, or a zero point, at that location
and so they are not affected
by me damping at that location.
And you can hear this really really clearly if
I put my finger very lightly on the 12th fret
you can see that most of
the sound is coming through
and it's a little bit higher pitched
that's because all of the even "n's", n=2, n=4, n=6,...
of those even n's
are being able to to come through even though
I'm damping... I'm kind of like holding
a little bit of a damper at this point.
All ofthe even and sine waves are not affected
because they perfectly kind of pass through
that zero point where i'm holding my finger.
Whereas if I pick a random location and I putmy finger there,
I'm kind of killing all of thewaves and I'm killing all of that sound.
Maybethis will make more sense if I pick one string
and it's twice the frequency, n=2,
so that's kind of cool anyway
this is just uh an example of how
you can get some intuition so i always like to
think about these these kind of wave physics
with an intuitive example you could pick
maxwell's equation you could pick uh you know
ripples on a lake i like the guitar string because
i think it's very intuitive uh how these sounds
are being generated you can put your finger in
different places to change l you can increase
the tension or decrease the tension you can go to
a string that has lower density or higher density
and all of those change the frequency of the sound
good um yeah one last thing i want to show you and
this is going to end up being an entire additional
lecture so i'm going to very likely have a whole
lecture on the method of characteristics which
is a very very very important idea in these
this is called a hyperbolic partial
differential equation so this is a hyperbolic
hyperbolic pde which basically means that
there is a speed of information propagation
uh in the in the problem because there's
a speed of sound and for hyperbolic pdes
there is something called the method of
characteristics method of characteristic
i believe this was also invented by dalon bear
when he derived this this wave equation i'm not
100 sure um but i think so and i'm going to have
a whole whole lecture on this but what i want to
show you is that when you have sine of something
times cosine of something you can use the
trig identity a really really simple trig
identity which is sine of a times cos of b
equals one half sine of a plus b
plus sine of a minus b this is just a
trigonometric identity you can verify this
yourself but because all of our solutions have the
form sine of something times cosine of something
i can essentially use those
to write down the following
essentially my solution is going to be
you know u of x and t
equals i don't want to write this
i'm going to say this is equal to
the sum from n equals 0 to infinity of that
constant c n divided by 2 times now i'm going
to have a sine of this plus this plus sine of
this minus this so that's sine of n pi over l
x plus n pi over l c t so i'm just going to
say plus c t and uh plus sine i'll just i'll go
back in and uh we'll double check that i didn't
mess anything up n pi over l and now it's this
minus this so that's x minus ct and so this is
really really really interesting what this says
is that because of this trig identity sine of a
times cos b equals you know one half sine a plus b
plus sine of a minus b i can take these and you
can verify for yourself that you know n pi over
l times x and n pi over l times c t give you
this expression when you use this trig identity
what we find is that essentially our solution u
of x and t is given by two these are called waves
that are traveling in different directions
so x plus c t is a solution that is traveling
in one direction as time increases
this is kind of shifting my solutions
uh i think this is shifting my solutions if
if time increases then x has to be you know
negative to make this zero and this other part
here is traveling in the other direction so i'm
just going to draw a little picture here this is
like a teaser for later and i'm going to have a
whole lecture on this method of characteristics
is that if i have some initial condition
essentially i have information traveling this is x
and this is time so if i have a little disturbance
that disturbance is going to travel in the right
direction and in the left direction because of
these two decompositions here so i'm going to
have a whole lecture going over the method of
characteristics which is how you can take these
wave equation solutions here and you can write
them in terms of these uh kind of left and right
traveling waves that give you kind of this this
interesting um behavior but i'll do that at a
later a later date okay good um we have derived
the wave equation in the previous lecture in this
lecture we solved it using separation of variables
we tied that solution to some physical intuition
on a guitar string so like literally what is the
frequency of sound you hear as a function of you
know the length of the string the tension the
material things like that and we showed that using
this trig identity you can rewrite the solution
in this intriguing form here where i now have
this kind of interesting anti-symmetric left
traveling wave and right traveling wave and so
this is the basis of the method of characteristics
which will be another lecture for
another day all right thank you